welcome back to the show I'm your host
mark today is delaying the Roth Johnson
versus Jason Statham they start to
gather in Hobbs and Shaw the new Fast
and Furious spin-off that gives them a
chance to flex their biceps without Vin
Diesel napping through the fun they're
both great action stars and we're gonna
take a look at their storied careers and
see who comes out on top it's about to
get oily folks you think I'm just your
pal of course I think you're stupid
but you know what I'll do you a favor
I'm not that dumb right out of your
skull you just say the word chat here's
our competition works round one box
office round 2 tomato meter round 3
toughest opponent and we'll do a
wild-card round that could involve
push-ups kettle bell rose or who can eat
the most in one sitting
have you seen The Rock's Instagram the
dudes cheat days are legendary
all right here we go I'm what you call a
nice cold can of whoop-ass you must have
misplaced that when I'll kick your ass
up and down that officer yours round one
box on both bells have proven they're
bankable action stars over there 31
movie careers yep
they both each have done 31 movies that
we had box-office Intel on and ever
since we first saw the rock step out of
the WWE ring and into the talking
pictures he's been a force his flicks
have gross they combined 4.1 billion
dollars domestically and that makes for
an average outing of a hundred and
thirty three point six million dollars
beat that Statham he can't he's done
well his movies have earned a total of
2.4 billion dollars and that's an
average of 80 point 8 million bucks per
film but maybe do less mechanics and
more Meigs yeah we want more giant
sharks look it's cool to hook up with
Jessica Alba on a beach but if you want
an audience to get in the theater get in
the water and battle a giant prehistoric
monster what I'd like distant blade I
can't say I would take that advice
myself but I would like you to do it
Jason
well I'll make a habit of doing things
that people say I can't do walk through
fire water-ski blindfolded take up piano
a late age rock also has the highest
grossing domestic film of either fella
and it's not a fast and furious movie
it's actually Jumanji welcome to the
jungle Statham's highest-grossing film
is drumroll please we still don't have
sound effects okay its Furious 7 which
also stars Dwayne so the rock wins this
round easy and he's off to a one to
nothing start scorchin round two tomato
meter okay two way and so your movies
make tons of cash but are they cinema I
never do Jason Statham has an impressive
tomato meter resume he can do crime
thrillers like snatching the Italian job
he can do comedy like in his highest
charting tomato meter film spy at 94% I
go into the face/off machine get old
advice what's up and of course he has
lent his fresh scent to franchises like
fast and furious and crank but in the
other corner is the rock the self touted
franchise viagra that sponsor the show
yet give it a couple years for me his
highest charting movie on the tomato
meter is Moana yep he sings and dances
and everything it's 96 percent fresh but
his best live-action rating is 92
percent for fighting with my family
where he plays the rock and while Dwayne
edges out Statham for average movie
rating he's at forty nine point eight
percent Jason is forty six point six
percent most of Dwayne's hits are in big
name ensemble blockbusters like fast and
furious is and Jumanji when it's him and
just him on the marquee he's not as
bulletproof state them has freshness in
and out of franchises so while both bros
can do much more than just kick ass on
screen its Jason who takes this round we
are tied at one each and it's still
anyone's ballgame
okay thanks lunch lady round three
toughest opponent yeah well every boxer
seems to have a record of like thirty
wins and two losses so the question
becomes who do you beat shockingly both
men cancel each other out with their
monster centric battles
Jason crushed the Meg and had a sweet
Godzilla fight scene and cranked to and
meanwhile the rock emerged victorious
against a giant crocodile a huge wolf a
giant pig gorilla who ended up being
friendly I love me some George
son of a [ __ ] Statham was taking out a
bunch of cops before turning good ish in
the Fast and Furious universe and he
also wiped out dozens of soldiers in the
Dungeon Siege movie you remember that
it's okay nobody remembers the actual
name of that it had a king or a name or
something in there but Dwayne ooh boy
he's decimated an entire army in the run
down defeated another army and Hercules
and he punched an earthquake into
submission in San Andreas he didn't
actually punch it but it's like the
earthquake flexed and then the rock
flexed and the earthquake was like
mother of my bad dude let me buy you a
drink the rock and our wild-card round
who wins in a fight let's cut to the
chase since the dawn of action stars
it's always fun to see who would beat up
who slivers is Arnie hey that's a vid
you can watch Van Damme versus the Ghul
which I will totally do if somebody
allows me and now the rock versus Jason
Statham the former wrestler versus the X
member of Britain's national swimming
squad hmm but this isn't about who can
follow a storyline better who can swim
the English Channel the fastest
mano-a-mano
now based on fast and furious logic
state them should win he got the better
of Dwayne in Furious 7 and they battled
to a tie in the fate of the Furious who
wins the eye test it's the rock come on
they will not stop until you feed them
he's too big too much destruction
according to our researchers he's caused
12 trillion dollars of damage in his
flicks he simply does not go down but is
that him or is it his stunt double
Statham famously doesn't like actors who
set off the stunts he does most of his
own stunts even if it almost kills him
which came close to doing just that on
the set of Expendables 3 for reals
YouTube it so like 60 feet at the bottom
of the blacks a stuck in the mud
thinking hang on a minute I'm going to
get out of this this is how it ends so
while the rock is put on up to 30 pounds
of muscle for roles like pain and gain
Statham added two hours of combat
training a day to prep for the
expendables I haven't done two hours of
combat training in my entire life plus
Statham won the bottle cap challenge I'm
shocked that this is happening I can't
believe I'm gonna do this in a vid that
goes out to people but I got to give it
to Statham he wins the round
Down Goes Johnson Down Goes Johnson
nobody tell the rock I voted against it
please do not let him see this this all
has been ripped off completely and
reattached with this [ __ ] arm that's
possible so we're tied at two and I have
to make a decision that will define my
judgement for the rest of my days this
is my moment to choose what will be
remembered for all eternity the rock the
rock is the pit if you had to start a
franchise with one star regardless of
the genre its Dwayne Johnson Statham is
great and did a fantastic job hanging in
against one of the world's biggest stars
and he may get the ultimate win how
because you the viewer decide I'm just
one vote here and you could vote right
now by typing your winner into the
comment section and defend your choice
as I have valiantly defended mine here
today we'll be looking and we'll hope to
see you on another episode real soon and
I hope that episode is the Van Damme
versus the goal one n each No
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]